[Music]
now steve uh congrats you have an uh a
show a new television show but the real
congratulations uh is that you had a uh
a baby girl recently is that right yes
unbelievable incredible how's that going
i was just seeing how long i could go
with this yeah
apparently it's it's been great it's
been great it's uh you know it's weird
having a baby girl uh
i started realizing how bad i feel for
girls because girls are forced to grow
up so quick uh you think about it what's
the first toy little boy gets a gun
truck a bike what's first toy little
gorgeous another little baby girl right
that's kind of myself like hey i'm a
baby so much fun time to grow up baby
here's your baby
i just got here
what's that kitchen set for get in there
you learn how to bake
cookies even girls you got to keep that
alive yeah
that's a lot of responsibility you're
right and girls grow up so quick even by
the laws of nature when does a girl
technically become a woman fifth grade
remember the one day the teacher comes
in separates a class life changes after
the day teacher comes in all right all
the girls follow me come on we gotta
have a little conversation girls go
what's going on is there a rainbow
outside
girls come back 20 minutes later i'm so
scared
because that's scary news you're a kid
you're on a jungle gym going down a
slide next you know you're in a cold
class with a teacher you're going to be
bleeding once a month pretty much the
rest of your life
you're going to be bleeding oh yeah from
where right there
is it going to hurt not you but everyone
around you
yes
oh you did it
i did it
boy i'll tell you after dennis leary's
story i got to say this i'm horny you're
horny well you know the rest
now you'd think that becoming a dad
yes you'd think that becoming a father
would make you more mature that was
but apparently no that is not that it's
not the case no no i remember uh i was
holding him one day and she was just
dead asleep and her name's olivia so i
should just preface that not that it's
important to the story but her name is
olivia so i'm holding her she's dead
asleep and i for some reason i started
doing the wrestling thing like the hulk
hogan thing when you put the army where
you lift it up yeah i was just lifting
her arm up and it kept dropping i i
couldn't stop laughing i was looking my
chest come like check this out
down for the count it's a choke hold and
then all of a sudden the arm stayed up
and then she opened her eyes and looked
at me i was like oh my god this is
awesome and she threw up all over
[Applause]